[Musique]
valentino disait je sais ce que veulent
les femmes elles veulent être belles
c'est vrai mais c'est pas tout en fait
on veut être plus belle plus mince et
plus jeunes aussi parfois vous n'êtes
pas d'accord avec ça je suis photographe
spécialisé dans les portraits de femmes
et jamais aucune de mes clientes ne m'a
dit qu'elle ne voudrait rien changé à
son apparence on veut tout être belle à
l'intérieur comme à l'extérieur surtout
à l'extérieur
mais l'extérieur parfois on l aime pas
beaucoup quand on parle l'extérieur on
peut faire référence à sa magnifique
photo pour une célèbre marque de
lingerie placardé sur tous les murs de
ma ville quand j'étais jeune et aussi
magnifique que soit cette photo et ses
fesses ça ne me donne pas du tout envie
de vous montrer les miennes
au contraire cette photo me dit tes
fesses ne ressemble pas à ça et la seule
chose à laquelle je pense c'est que sur
mon corps ça ne rendra mais jamais
pareil il manque quelques bourrelets un
peu de cellulite quelques vergetures
merci pour le sentiment d'infériorité et
bizarrement parfois je me dis que c'est
possible que je pourrais ressembler à ça
parce que tout ce qu'on voit à la
télévision nous parle de transformation
transformation de corps de visages de
coupe de cheveux de style de mode de vie
tout nous crie qu'on peut être une
meilleure personne qu'il ya place à
l'amélioration et la plupart des
couvertures de magazines ne nous aide
pas parce que même si on sait que tout
est retouché
on éprouve quand même un sentiment
d'infériorité et personne n'y échappe
hommes ou femmes quel que soit notre âge
et notre tour de taille
on a souvent une relation compliquée
avec notre corps moi je rêve de voir une
de mes clientes en couverture parce
qu'elle deviendrait un modèle pour
d'autres jeunes et moins jeunes
notre société a besoin de modèles il
faut leur en donner des vrais
diversifiée accessible sans leur donner
un idéal impossible à atteindre presque
des femmes de toutes les tailles de tous
les âges
pourquoi ne voit-on que très peu de
couvertures avec des femmes de 30 40 50
ans ou plus est-ce qu'on est laide passé
vingt ans vous madame vous où vous vous
êtes magnifique
vous avez une histoire des valeurs à
partager vous devriez être en première
page malheureusement c'est pas très
souvent ce qu'on voit sur les
couvertures et dès qu'il est question de
se faire prendre en photo j'entends
souvent les mêmes choses moi j'aime pas
les photos à je déteste les photos je
suis pas photogénique
ou alors oui un jour quand et vous
pouvez remplir les blancs quand j'aurai
perdu 5 10 15 20 livres quand mes shows
seront plus longs quand mes dons seront
plus blanche quand mes enfants seront
plus grands
on trouve toujours une excuse
ce que j'entends derrière le moi je
m'aime pas en photo c'est simplement moi
je ne m'aime pas et je sais ce que c'est
j'ai derrière moi une longue carrière de
sentiment d'infériorité de problèmes de
poids de manque de confiance
je me suis jamais trouvée jolie quand
j'étais jeune j'étais en surpoids et je
pensais pouvoir combler le vide et
trouver la solution dans le frigo dans
une paire de chaussures plus tard dans
une bouteille de vin
mais on sait très bien que rien de tout
ça ne fonctionne de fuir c'est que c'est
pas le manque d'amour des autres qui
nous fait chercher le réconfort dans la
nourriture ou d'autres choses c'est le
manque d'amour de nous mêmes c'est
incroyable cette difficulté qu'ont à
être gentil avec soi même assez mais
c'est nous qui choisissons cette douleur
personne ne nous l'imposent il n'ya que
nous pour nous aimer et nous traiter
avec amour et respect et il est temps de
le faire parce que soyons honnêtes on
est un peu coincé dans notre corps et
dont nous mêmes
alors autant composer avec du mieux
qu'on peut et heureusement parfois
quelque chose quelqu'un va venir vont
nous montrer qu'il ya une autre voie
possible va venir nous aider à nous
réconcilier avec nous mêmes parce qu'il
ya toujours quelqu'un pour traverser nos
murs de peur tel un fantôme et nous voir
belle et nous aimer malgré l'apparence
que nous affichons malgré tout ce que
nous pouvons penser de nous les gens
lisent dans notre coeur et dans nos yeux
pour voir notre beauté parce que c'est
là qu'elle se trouve
c'est l'amour et la confiance qui crée
la beauté non les archétypes de mode qui
changent au fil des siècles la première
fois pour moi c'est passé par la danse
c'est ma passion mon oxygène quand
j'étais petit j'avais dit à ma mère je
voulais être danseuse elle m'a répondu
que j'étais trop grosse pour être
danseuse puis que c'était pas un vrai
métier
j'ai quand même continuer de danser
caché au fond de la salle
en évitant les regarde trop insistant
sur mon corps dans le miroir et j'étais
plutôt bonne et un jour j'ai croisé le
chemin de deux femmes sans qui je serai
pas qui je suis aujourd'hui deux profs
de danse extraordinaire laure
courtellemont et agnès copé je faisais
deux heures de train chaque semaine pour
aller reprendre leur cours à paris
parfois plusieurs fois par semaine ce
qu'elles m'ont appris c'est que peu
importe la couleur de ta peau ton âge ta
taille des courbes des croyances la
danse c'est pour tout le monde parce que
quand tu danses avec ton coeur et que tu
partages tu rayonne et chaque être
humain a droit de se sentir exister de
se sentir bien
c'est ça qu'elle véhicule en leurs cours
et saissac elles m'ont appris j'ai passé
une audition pour rentrer dans leurs
troupes de profs ragga jam la première
et unique audition de ma vie terrorisée
par mais tous les profs de danse de
fitness et autres danseurs
professionnels avec à côté de moi mais
j'ai réussi je suis parti en formation
intensive et j'ai pleuré toutes les
larmes de mon corps pendant une semaine
parce que je voulais partager ma passion
faire exister les autres comme je me
sentais existe et moi quand je danse et
la seule chose que j'avais pour la faire
c'était mon corps ce corps avec lequel
j'étais pas en harmonie que j'aimais pas
parce que trop grand parce que trop de
bourrelets parce que trop de ceci ou pas
assez cela
bref j'ai quand même réussi à passer au
travers parce que j'avais pas vraiment
le choix
et surtout on prend en compte que en
acceptant d'être vulnérable en
partageant je recevais mille fois plus
et c'est moi qui ne sentaient existait
autant que mes danseurs pour la première
fois j'étais réconcilier avec mon corps
et je mets mais je suis arrivé au québec
il ya sept ans et pour les bonnes et les
mauvaises raisons j'ai arrêté de danser
quand je suis tombée enceinte j'ai pris
du poids beaucoup de poids 75 livres
parce que moi je fais jamais les choses
à moitié
comment j'ai fait c'est pas en fait j'ai
commencé à écouter cette petite voix
dans ma tête je pense que vous la
connaissez aussi c'est celle qui dit
toujours qu'on n'est pas assez bien
quand on a des grosses fesses ou qu'on
en a pas c'est qu'on a passé poitrine
qu'on en a trop qu'on n'est pas assez
intelligente qu'on n'est pas assez
talentueuse qu'on ait une mauvaise mère
une mauvaise épouse une mauvaise amis ou
tout autre faille dans laquelle elle
s'engouffre parce qu'elle sait où aller
et qui fait mal le pire c'est que si
cette petite voix était une vraie
personne on en voudrait même pas que
mamie alors pourquoi est ce qu'on les
écoute
pourquoi mon conway soin de confiance
pourquoi est-ce qu'on lui laisse autant
de place moi je vais laisser toute la
place
j'ai connu la période post accouchement
version pyjama confortable avec chandail
surdimensionné pour être bien sûr de
cacher mon corps reléguant de maquillage
et la brosse à cheveux dans une galaxie
très très très lointaine bien moment il
a bien fallu que je remette un vrai
pantalon pour aller travailler et quand
on va faire une séance de magasinage
avec cette petite amie dans la tête
c'est pas évident ça se termine
inévitablement par une séance de bouffe
réconfort à la maison histoire d'en
rajouter une couche
littéralement
et un jour j'ai vu quelque chose de
magique dans les yeux de mon fils d'à
peine quelques mois l'amour et quand il
a commencé à parler un jour il m'a dit
t'es belle maman pour monfils
même en mode pyjama j'étais belle lui me
voyais autrement que moi je me voyais
parce qu'il m'aimait profondément moi je
trouvais plus facile de l'aimer lui
plutôt que de mai mais moi même le
problème c'est que les enfants
n'apprennent pas de nos paroles ils
apprennent de nos actes comment
apprendre à mon fils à s'aimer lui même
si j'en étais incapable même si je
l'encourageais chaque jour et que je lui
dis des belles choses
pas de ce que je vais lui dire qu'il va
apprendre c'est de ce que je vais lui
montrer ce besoin d'approbation et de
reconnaissance que nous cherchons tous
de nos parents général il ne peut jamais
venir ou venir très tard c'est à nous de
faire ce travail c'est à nous de montrer
l'exemple à nos enfants
sinon ils seront remplis de peur de
manque de confiance de sentiment d'auto
destruction et nous verrons ça dans leur
regard et sanou brisera le coeur parce
que c'est nous qui leur ont montré il
n'ya que nous pour nous aimer et nous
traiter avec amour et respect je pas en
train de vous dire que cette petite voix
ne revient pas ce serait beaucoup trop
facile elle et moi savons qu'au tout a
beaucoup trop loin je dirais depuis
l'adolescence c'est intéressant comme
relation mais aujourd'hui à la dôle
moins en moins de pouvoir sur moi j'ai
37 ans et comme dirait ma mère des
courbes généreuses
c'est la vie elle est remplie de
merveilleux moment j'essaye tous les
jours de grandir aussi bien
personnellement que professionnellement
j'adore mon travail j'adore danser
partager photographier les gens et je
choisis aujourd'hui d'être assez bien
maintenant j'ai pas besoin d'être plus
mince j'ai pas besoin d'être plus jeune
je veux quelque chose maintenant
mon corps est parfait maintenant il tend
bonne santé et ça suffit souvent pensé
que tout ça était ma plus grande
faiblesse
mais j'ai réalisé qu'en fait c'est ma
plus grande force parce que je
photographie des femmes et que je veux
photographier chaque femme qui s'est
déjà regarder dans un miroir et qui ne
s'est pas senti bien pour lui montrer
comment les gens la voient et pour
qu'elles changent le regard qu'elle a
sur elle parce que chaque photo à mon
empreinte celle d'une petite fille qui a
trouvé la beauté de la femme qu'elle a
devant elle et qui veulent à lui montré
pour que cette magnifique femme ne se
sentent plus jamais mal pour lui montrer
que la saboter n'est pas dans l'image
déformée que lui renvoie le miroir mais
bien dans l'image de papier que je lui
montre sa vraie beauté débarrasser de la
peur du regard des autres
de ce sentiment d'anxiété générés par je
ne sais quel mensonge qu'on s'est bâti
et qui nous a laissés nous replier sur
nous-mêmes
jusqu à nous étouffer nous laisser
parfois dans un état fantomatique une
amp transparente de nous mêmes je le
fais parce que je connais ce long chemin
pavé de manque de confiance et que ça ne
me contrôle plus aujourd'hui je le fais
parce que nous devons changer le regard
que nous avons sur nous mêmes maintenant
parce que nous devons nous aimer
maintenant est célébrée qui nous sommes
maintenant merci
[Applaudissements]